ev startup rivian
started trading on wednesday and the
stock has popped 60 and peaked at
over a 100
billion valuation
uh they of course have no revenue so
as of midday thursday uh the stocks
settled at around 117 a share that
represents around 100 billion dollar
market cap in other words
it's worth what airbnb uber and other
companies that have tens of billions of
dollars in revenue is worth and those
are obviously much better businesses the
company has made zero revenue uh as of
their s1 from october 1st their
projected best case scenario for q3 is a
million in revenue uh obviously quarter
three and september 30th uh for those of
you who are not familiar and as of
september 30th rivien reported 48 000
pre-orders for both the r1t and the r1s
this is their pickup truck which is um
pretty good looking uh i think it's
looks
essentially
like a pickup truck with a nice set of
lights um not really much different than
a pickup truck you might see
from ford to be totally honest and i
think that was their design choice was
to just say hey this is really easy for
somebody who owns a ford 150 of course
since they announced ford announced that
they're doing an electric 150 so i think
uh that's going to be a big problem for
rivian to be totally honest because ford
can lose money on the 150. i i don't
think ford is as far behind today
as it was when tesla came out over a
decade ago so let's put that on the side
for a second
these customers paid a cancelable and
fully refundable deposit of one thousand
dollars so they have 48 million dollars
in deposits
uh remember jason's law i tell you about
this all the time if a company has a
billion dollar valuation before they
have revenue or a product in market it's
either a fraud or it's going to fail um
this has been true almost universally uh
we saw it with
nicola
we might be seeing it with magic leave
unknown uh if magic leaps ever gonna get
to profitability or products in market
uh was the last time anybody used a
magically product
uh varanos falls into this category
nicola quibby
would be uh which you know wasn't a
terrible product but it wasn't a great
product either and
i give them credit for trying but it did
command a huge valuation
so i always get worried when the
valuation gets too high compared with
the performance
and that's
uh coming for me as an investor in
private companies you would think i'd be
like yeah let it rip you know it's good
for me if these things rip why wouldn't
i as an investor want to see valuations
disconnect from reality well because i
don't think it's sustainable i would
like there to be a sustainable
environment for startups and for
high-tech companies a company with no
delivered vehicles becoming worth
100 billion dollars is absolutely insane
now
this might be a case where jason's law
does not actually wind up
applying it could wind up not being a
fraud and it could wind up being
successful i think nikola fisker and
some of these other electric vehicle
startups are nowhere near where rivien
is based on what i can see it has an
estimated range of 314 miles it starts
at 67k
but i don't think that's the actual
price um i think it winds up being
closer to you know 90 or 100.
uh as of september 30th 2021 we produced
12 r1ts and delivered 11.
now
all of these vehicles seem to be have
delivered to their employees in other
words
it sounds like they're bespoke
handcrafted
uh
vehicles this is what tesla called the
founder series uh or you know basically
prototypes so
uh by october 31st we produced 180 r1ts
and delivered 156 so that's 145
delivered in october i guess they timed
this to be when they were delivering
their products quoting uh riven nearly
all of these vehicles were delivered to
rivien employees and we expect to ramp
deliveries to third-party consumers as
we increase our production rate that's a
big red flag um it's not uncommon to
give the first ones to employees
obviously the employees are not going to
rip it to shreds
and the founder series that tesla did go
out to the early investors i had a
founder series of model three obviously
people famously know i have signature
zero zero one
of the model s and uh that's a
collectible uh that i think i'm gonna
maybe donate to the smithsonian or
something if i don't know if there's a
place where i can donate this million
dollar car so i can get out of my garage
and they could maybe insure it and put
it on display if there's a car
if and listen the folks at rally road i
gotta get back to them they were very
nice they wanted to auction off the
signature one and my roadster 16. i
haven't done that but i would like to
put them in a museum somewhere if
somebody wanted to if they're is there a
great museum that takes these cars and
you know we'll take custodianship of
them and i don't know if i want to give
it to them yet or donate it but i would
like to just have it on display
somewhere like two of the first be kind
of cool
so uh here's a tweet from a rivian
employee travis munson on october 22nd
the r1t truck has been driven and
reviewed by the press though uh
bloomberg motor trend roadshow and cnet
and they've generally been positive
noting the large storage space bloomberg
noted the truck is cute but not a badass
pickup truck not sure i'm looking for
bloomberg for their take on these amazon
and ford own about a third of the
company combined and those are really
two good votes of confidence uh amazon
owns 20 which is now worth over 20
billion dollars i wonder if that's bezos
trying to stick it to elon you know they
have that little back and forth over
rocket ships and ford owns a 12 percent
stake valued at over 10 billion so you
have to wonder like
what's going on with the relationship
with ford and rivian
ford
just was it six months ago that they
announced the electric f-150 and they
kind of surprised the market with that
announcement that this was coming and
like ford owns 12 of a company that
they're the number one competitor of i
mean how does that work i mean obviously
ford is getting an education here but i
don't think they're hedging their bet at
all
i think they want to win the category so
that's got to be interesting at 12
percent you would have a board seat but
how do you give a board seat to ford
maybe ford thinks they have a chance to
buy the company uh but now that the
market caps 100 billion is more than
what ford's worth so rivien with zero
well with 150 cars delivered to their
employees could buy forward or be an
equal merger it's bizarre i mean the
world has literally gotten disconnected
from reality that doesn't mean riven is
not a real product a real company so let
me be clear about that i actually think
they're more real than like let's say
fisker which i think is going to be just
a total
washout like nicola because fisker
everything he touches seems to die
you know it's like the third time
they've resuscitated the carcass of
fisker um and their cars are ugly and
ferocious and i never liked him or the
cars i'll be totally honest uh in the
2.5 years prior to growing public ribbon
raised 10 billion uh over 10 billion
most recent round they closed was 2.5
billion in july
they raised
almost 12 billion for the ipo which is
great they have a war chest so good for
them
amazon has ordered a hundred thousand
riven delivery vehicles be delivered by
2030
so that is a pretty big deal to have
amazon as a customer
and obviously
bezos cares deeply about the climate as
do most i think people in the world who
have any any trust of the scientific
method or
uh have read a newspaper or opened their
eyes and gone outside and seen the
extreme weather according to cnbc rivian
reserves seven percent of its ipo
allocation for a direct share program
for people who pre-ordered uh and
apparently you know collectively the
headline is they made millions of
dollars but i think it was 175 shares
was what they were allocated each
somebody could check me on that
which means you know people may have
made enough not to cover the cost uh but
it made a little bit
it's that time of year again the
holidays are coming up and have you been
thinking about upgrading your tech i bet
you have and if so you can take
advantage of dell technology's black
friday sneak peek cell that's right it's
powerful tech and perfect timing you're
going to save over 45
on some of dell's latest products
including dell's new mobile monitors
that can travel with you on the go
they're amazing have you ever been to a
coffee shop and thought you know what i
wish i had another monitor i do i travel
with one and now you can connect with
just a usbc cable boom now you got
double the productivity maybe you even
want to put two of those on that's a
power move when i go to hotels you'll
see me i've got my three monitor setup
and it's amazing and here at home i have
my three beautiful dell monitors as well
so here's what you can do you just visit
dell.com twist d-e-l-l dot com slash
twist and you can save up to 45 today at
dell.com twist no need to wait till
black friday you can do it right now